As an example, here's my blog, circa an embarassingly
short time ago. Now, if you resize this window,
nothing really changes. Nothing adjusts other than
the amount of margin space. It's really
a fixed width layout. Now, let's take a look at this on the phone.
Now here, I get a very different version of my
blog. It fits well on the phone, but I'm only
getting this because my blog is running on Wordpress. And,
Wordpress is configured to give a totally different version to phones.
But, that's not actually what I want. Because I really
want to have a shared layout between the two. Let's
take a look at this on a intermediate device. My
seven inch Android tablet. Now here, what I'm getting is essentially
the desktop version. I can still scroll through the
site but you can tell all the text is pretty
small. Although interestingly, if I rotate to landscape mode,
it adapts. Now why does it do that? Well it
turns out it's our old friend viewport. There's now
viewport set in this page. So, what does that mean?
Does layout happen if the device flipped? Or does layout
happen at the magic 980 pixel width and then get
rescaled to fit on the screen?